[Elevator music playing]
[Mobius sighs]
MOBIUS
I'm Agent Mobius, by the way.
LOKI
Are you taking me somewhere to kill me?
MOBIUS
No. That's where you just were.
I'm taking you
someplace to talk.
LOKI
Well, I don't like to talk.
MOBIUS
But you do like to lie,
which you just did.
Because we both know,
you love to talk.
Talky, talky.
LOKI
How long have you been here?
MOBIUS
I don't know, it's hard to say.
You know, time passes
differently here in the TVA.
LOKI
What does that mean?
MOBIUS
You'll catch up.
LOKI
So you're part of the TVA's
courageous and
dedicated workforce?
MOBIUS
Yes.
LOKI
You were created by the Time-Keepers...
MOBIUS
Yep.
LOKI
...to protect the sacred timeline?
MOBIUS
Correct.
[Loki laughs]
MOBIUS
Is that funny?
LOKI
The idea that your little club
decides the fate of trillions
of people across all of existence
at the behest
of three... Space lizards?
Yes, it's funny.
It's absurd.
MOBIUS
I thought you didn't like to talk?
[Loki scoffs]